make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we're back with another what-if
video and since we've done videos in
this series featuring the red lantern
rings and the orange lantern rings I
thought I'd focus on the Black Lantern
ring now this is probably the last one
we're gonna do at least as far as the
Lantern rings for a little while it's
like Good Charlotte one set one time is
okay two times is fine three times
you're playing with yourself so we're
gonna stop after three and then we're
gonna kind of call it a day early so we
might come back after a while but we're
gonna do a what a story on something
else next week but in thinking about who
would do something interesting with a
black Lantern ring I came to the
conclusion that the best candidate for
receiving this ring would actually be
Magneto now that might not seem like an
obvious choice but I think it makes
sense because magneto has a very
specific objective that he's basically
been trying to achieve since we were
introduced to the character the
overthrow of the human race and the
establishment of a new world order where
mutants assume their rightful place of
dominance over mankind
and although magneto is extremely
powerful being an omega-level mutant in
his own right he's never been able to
achieve this on his own and so it makes
sense that if he were to gain access to
something that could give him a
significant bump in power that he might
actually be able to accomplish his goal
also I want to set the parameters for
this story in terms of where in the
Marvel chronology this hypothetical
story would take place and so I
definitely want this to take place
before the current x-men status quo of
all the mutants living on krikawa and
being able to resurrect dead mutants
went into effect and I think the best
place for this story to occur is just
before the events of Avengers vs. x-men
and the vision that I have for this is
that it'll actually take the place of
Avengers vs. x-men because I think a lot
of people were fairly underwhelmed with
that story or at least underwhelmed with
the vs. portion of that story I kind of
was the vs. series was cool because you
got to see x-men fight Avengers but I
felt like it was one of those things
where Marvel started off strong they
were like yeah this is gonna be awesome
why issue number one's gonna be amazing
I like the six vs. issue it was like
okay so like we're done now and I didn't
care they were just kind of like new
stuff things and stuff then that was
basically yet but the first thing we
have to figure out is how magneto gets
his hands on a Black Lantern ring at
this time magneto is actually a member
of the x-men but his alliance with the
x-men has always been a bit tenuous as
some members of the team have a hard
time getting past the fact that he's
tried to kill them like a million times
which is fair so as it turns out their
suspicion is justified and it turns out
that magneto is not 100% committed to
Xavier dream
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants and then he's actually been
meeting in secret with the Scarlet Witch
who at this point was still candidly
recognized as being the daughter of
magneto Scarlet Witch as you probably
know is an extremely powerful magic
wielder and in this story we learned
that her abilities had actually grown to
the point that she's able to travel
between dimensions and as part of her
alliance with her father she's been
looking for powerful artifacts to aid
his quest for mutant supremacy now you
could probably guess from the premise of
this video that one of those artifacts
is the Black Lantern ring and so she
travels to the DC Universe learns about
the ring and then takes it back to
Magneto who keeps it in his proverbial
back pocket and so the perfect
opportunity to use it presents itself
now another thing that happened in the
x-men line of comics at this time was
the impending return of the Phoenix
force and his anticipated union with
Hope Summers it's chosen host now the
conflict over what should be done about
this set the Avengers and the x-men at
odds with one another with the Avengers
wanting to prevent the Phoenix from
possessing hope and the x-men welcoming
it as a rebirth of their species in this
version of the story however instead of
allowing war to break out between the
Avengers and the x-men which he fears
will lead to the unnecessary deaths of
many of his fellow mutants once the
Avengers make known their intentions to
take hope into custody magneto dons the
Black Lantern ring and sets in motion
the eradication of mankind to pave the
way for a world where mutants reign
supreme
without fear of interference from
humanity now once he wields a Black
Lantern ring magneto is able to
reanimate the dead and use them as his
own personal army his move is to go to
the ruined island of Genosha which was
once a mutant paradise to some 16
million mutants inhabiting it but was
ultimately reduced to rubble and most of
its citizens killed by Cassandra Nova's
wild sentinels and just by going there
magneto is able to raise for himself an
army of millions of slain mutants which
not only has symbolic significance
because it turns the greatest massacre
of mutant kind into a weapon that could
be used for humanity's undoing but also
makes Magneto and his hordes of
reanimated mutant zombies the most
pressing threat to the Marvel Universe
unfortunately for him this is also the
thing that causes the x-men and the
Avengers to put their differences aside
and unite against this new threat the
Avengers still think the Phoenix force
needs to be stopped but that must be
dealt with after Magneto's zombie horde
is defeated now the x-men do not respond
to Magneto's tactics here as although
they do want a resurgence of their
species they are totally unwilling
to side with Magneto and pursuing what
amounts to genocide and so rather than
hailing him as their savior as he had
hoped the x-men find themselves in the
familiar role of casting magneto as
their greatest villain and so the x-men
and The Avengers divided into strike
teams to respond to the several attacks
that magneto is orchestrating around the
globe meanwhile Professor X iron man
Black Panther Doctor Strange Namor and
Reed Richards known collectively as the
Illuminati meet to try and figure out a
way to neutralize Magneto's newfound
power now after some discussions they go
their respective ways hoping to find
anything they can to stop magneto
eventually Doctor Strange returns and
explains that he's followed the trail of
magic unwittingly left behind by Scarlet
Witch which led him to another dimension
where he learns about the Black Lantern
rings and how they can be defeated now
after explaining that there were rings
of other colors in that dimension
capable of negating the power of the
Black Lantern rings he also explains
that he was unable to bring them back
because bringing too much of that
universe into this one would weaken the
barrier between them and could open them
up to all sorts of new threats instead
he explains that it's the emotional
spectrum that's really the most
effective weapon against Magneto's Black
Lantern ring and that the Rings are
really just conduits through which
emotional energy is channeled and so
determining that willpower and any other
strong emotion will negate the effects
of the Black Lantern ring the Illuminati
formulate a plan to tap into Charles
Xavier telepathic ability to alter the
emotions of others and project these
emotions psychically to their teammates
that are on the ground fighting against
magneto zombies and so a Black Panther
and Ironman work on a way to try and
reconfigure cerebro to be able to boost
the emotional signal being sent out by
Xavier Xavier is also going to be
boosted by fellow telepaths Emma Frost
and her step4 kaku's as well as Hope
Summers whose mutant power is the
ability to copy or enhance the powers of
others and so while this is going on the
x-men and Avengers are actually fighting
these zombies and taking heavy losses
the zombies can be killed but only if
they're killed quickly enough that their
bodies cannot regenerate furthermore if
they aren't able to bite someone they're
able to turn them into a zombie as well
and so we've seen several heroes falling
in this manner once the Illuminati put
their plan into place however and Xavier
starts using his abilities to inspire
willpower and hope into the minds of the
heroes it actually seems to be working
and the heroes begin making headway in
taking out the zombie horde however
something goes completely wrong when
hope goes into shock
which greatly weakens the
signal of Xavier psychic boost to make
matters worse magneto is able to raise
more and more corpses faster than the
heroes can destroy them until they begin
to become overwhelmed in a battle of
attrition cutting back to hope it
quickly becomes clear that what the
Avengers had feared and the exponent
hoped for has finally happened and the
Phoenix force has returned to earth and
claimed hope as its host now the shock
and fear of the Phoenix's return quickly
turns to optimism as the Phoenix's
attention is clearly focused on Magneto
and its forces and so ultimately the
zombies are incinerated by the Phoenix
and hope seeks out and locates Magneto
now as I stand face to face magneto
tries desperately to explain that their
missions are aligned but hope completely
shuts him down stating that she's come
to bring life and that he's given the
planet to death and so she destroys the
Black Lantern ring purging the marvel
universe of his corrupting presence
before explaining that while she is able
to keep the Phoenix force in check for
now hope is fleeing earth in order to
figure out what degree she's able to
control it and so she flies off into
space leaving the Avengers and the x-men
to try to deal with the fallout from
Magneto's attack as well as prepare for
what happens if hope is unable to
control the Phoenix and comes back to
earth first they discuss what should
happen to magneto with each side arguing
that they should be the ones responsible
for taking him into custody as Captain
America and Cyclops argue Wolverine
enters the picture presumably to act as
a mediator but everyone is shocked when
he pops his claws and cuts Magneto's
head off on the spot everybody looks at
him and he says it he's tired of magneto
duping the x-men into thinking that he's
changed when he never would now that'll
never happen again and he turns in his
Avengers card and renounces his
membership in the x-men sick of being
torn between the two competing factions
and wanting no part of any upcoming
conflict between the two teams
ultimately he says when hope comes back
I'll know and if she's not in control
I'll be able to do what I need to do and
with that he walks away to forge his own
path independent of either team well he
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end that's kind of my thought on
this right it's not the the lengthiest
what-if story I thought it was kind of
cool right the idea of Maggie you know
getting a Lantern ring and then
resurrecting 16 million dead mutants and
then sitting them against like the world
I think it's kind of cool but let me
know you guys think like make sure you
guys leave a comment down below and let
me know what what a video you guys want
me to create like if you guys have like
it's a story do you want me to make
let me know what that is post that down
in the comment section and hopefully
we'll be able to cover for you guys but
when that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain to make sure you
guys with the sub button to become part
of the Rob core you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you